a European Union that wants to be a
union is facing a British referendum in
June brexit British exit the possibility
of British exit where's your contingency
plan for this well as a God's UK
referendum we know that heads of state
and government has made a deal reached
an agreement to address the concerns
raised by Prime Minister Cameron I also
contingency plans for your second
largest economy to leave the trading
block do you have contingent well now
that the decision is in the hands of
British people and I think so I decision
a contingency do you have contingency
planning well from Commission point of
view and this is also if you want
qualitative assessment of course it
makes economically much more sense for
the UK and also EU to stay within the
European Union stance so my question my
question was are you planning for the
contingency that Britain may leave the
European Union well after do we were
contributing to the solution which was
eventually reached by member states of
ensuring that this would not happen of
ensuring the oldest contingency plans
yes or no well once again supposed to be
a transparent organization when you took
the job your boss said I want
transparency in this commission I'm
asking you a very simple question do you
have contingency plans for Britain's
departure from the European Union our
plan on which we are working it's a plan
a for UK to stay within European Union
you know reuters reported in January
there's a senior Commission official
maybe it was you told them there is an
internal order not to discuss or study
the impact of British exit and this
comes from jean-claude yonkers office is
this why you can't give me a straight
answer because you've been told
absolutely nothing about this no this is
because we concentrate once again on the
plan a we concentration which is always
wrong make sure that UK stays as a part
of the EU which may makes much more
sense economically boss for UK and for
the EU so a level of incredible
irresponsibility then in your commission
that you're coming up to what could be a
major watershed event and you are making
no contingency plans whatsoever for it
is that what I can take away from your
answers what you can tell you take away
from the answers that it's best for EU
and UK to remain within the EU Valdis
Dombrovskis you've done your best not to
answer the question thank you very much
thank you thank you